YULIYA KLOCHAN: I'm
doing very well.
I'm very excited.
INTERVIEWER: Are you
excited, nervous?
YULIYA KLOCHAN: Yeah,
I'm very excited.
It's my first red
carpet premier,
which is what I think it is.
INTERVIEWER: What was the
hardest thing about this class?
YULIYA KLOCHAN: The
beginning was difficult
because there was a lot
of work you had to do,
and for me it kind of made
me realize what I know
and don't know.
So just getting rid of
all the misconceptions
I had about filmmaking,
script writing,
and all else was difficult.
INTERVIEWER: Do you feel like
you want to keep doing this,
or are you going to try to
take the things in the class
and apply it to non-video stuff?
YULIYA KLOCHAN: I'm
definitely interested
in educational resources.
So video, I think, is
one of the best mediums
to convey excitement about
science and mathematics.
So this is definitely something
that will be important in life.
INTERVIEWER: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER] How would
you describe this class
to someone who's
never taken it before?
YULIYA KLOCHAN: You
have a month to learn
how to make an
educational video,
and then you get to write,
produce, direct, and create it
all.
INTERVIEWER: Any words
of advice for people
who have never done it before?
YULIYA KLOCHAN: Don't think
it's going to be easy.
Just always think
that it's going
to be harder than you expected.
And put work into it.
INTERVIEWER: Thank
you very much.
YULIYA KLOCHAN: Thank you.